oh ok, ve mary kay por eso
Estados Unidos es un momento más seguro que
ecuaciones que perdí por los números
Agradecería un camino muy grueso.
Barack Obama es propenso a las grandes
diferencia de samba de 100 aquí o
prácticamente en casa estas medidas de seguridad
más alto nacional de los últimos cuatro
décadas con todo lo que compraremos
recursos y luego para entonces se acabó el champú
representa a las fuerzas militares y él
elaboración espacial añadida para tomar una
equipo que eliminó la libertad y esta será
emerge califato inauguró sus obras
revolviendo para matar los regalos del disco
bueno hay este en todos los que están matando mira
envío criminal
y luego a todas las chicas que presentas
El champú lo remató en la parte gruesa.
Llega el acuerdo nuclear con Irán, estoy listo.
él nunca ama a un amigo y miente que
Llame al bar y crea en los acuerdos de paz.
a Oriente Medio, donde el Bayern
se acercó a los editores en tren en
presentación durante una reunión
comunismo estados unidos y tampoco lo es
comparación mi padre lo ayudó
crecimiento en 50 años con
acuerdos comerciales que terminaron en
Ventas en Estados Unidos en las que estamos.
Miran al frente y mienten así.
mi padre lo permitió, lo lavarán con champú
yo estoy bien
y si entras dentro del rock y sueltas
Trate de ver que estas políticas no son
competidores neutrales solo meses
antes de que esté en este lugar para
Es una pena que en esta bañera sea para
eliminar amigos en los últimos 50 años uno
presidente se levantará en los estados
unidos en lo que ser el líder estados unidos
Orgulloso de estar en un país seguro y seguro.
la guerra y nuestros amigos sin nada y
quien vio una cara de guerra deja el
La pierna no es la de muchos otros compatriotas.
solo una casa vieja en
y ahi y miles provocan dice lo siguiente
buscando y reportando
agregar guerra o defender estados
intersección unida de esto entonces si todavía
Recordé por qué responden.
presidente y volvamos a mantener la
grandes estados unidos y
y ahí